منطقه اطلاق نار يمنع الدخول اليها هكذا
اعلنتها اسرائيل قبل سنوات وكان احدا لا
يسكن فيها وهكذا تعاملت مع اهلها وكانهم
مجرد سراب
مع ذلك عشتنا بسيطه جدا
والاحتلال ملحقنا عليها
بتفتش بالليل وبالنهار والحمد لله الله
كويس احنا راضيين بعيشتنا بس هم مش
سايبيننا بحالنا كنا هنا قبلهم وسنبقى
يقول ابو محمد وهو يستجمع ذاكره تجاوزت
ثمانين عاما وينفي ما يدعيه الاحتلال انها
كانت منطقه خاليه
[موسيقى]
في قريه اخرى كانت الذاكره اقل عمرا لكنها
امتلات بمشاهد الركام اذ يكبر حزن الاطفال
على هدم مدرستهم في مكان يعتبرون فيه اكبر
الاحلام مدرسه
لما اجوا هدول الجيش
زعلنا عشان نعدوها وبين بتتعلموا هلا نقرا
في عياده عياده الصحه وبنقرا في غرف ونقرا
في اخيها الهدف هو تهجير وتطهير عرق لهاي
المنطقه لاستبدالها بالمستوطنين والدليل
واضح اليوم امامنا في نفس الوقت اللي بده
يطرده الفلسطينيين من هاي المنطقه بحجه
منطقه اطلاق نار بنشوف كيف المستوطنين
بيستولوا عليها من كل جانب فوق مشقه
الحياه في قرى مسافه يضيف الاحتلال مشقات
فبعض الطرق اليها وعره واخرى مغلقه قبل
اشهر عده اقام لاحتلال الاسرائيلي هذا
الحاجز العسكري ليحاصر بذلك سكان قريتي
جنبه والمركز في مسافره ومنذ اذ لا يسمح
بالدخول من هنا الا لسكان المنطقه سنحاول
الوصول الى هذه القرى
بعد ساعات من الانتظار منعنا من عبور
الحاجز فالتقينا احد السكان عند اطراف
القريه
وانا مصاب بحجزني ثلث اربع ساعات الاقارب
اخوتي يعني اي ناس بده يجي يزورني بمنعوك
للمفارقه لا تعد المنطقه عسكريه مغلقه
بالنسبه الى المستوطنين وتوسعهم فهدف
اسرائيل لاستيلاء على هذه البقعه ايضا لكن
الغلابه كما يقول اهل الارض لمن يصبر على
قسوتها
نجوان سمري الجزيره من مسافري يطا جنوب
الضفه الغربيه